-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers
And this is "Late Night."
How's everybody doing tonight?
That is great to hear.
Let's get to the news.
Facebook's Oversight Board
announced today
that it will uphold
the company's decision
to suspend former
President Trump's account.
So whatever else
you think of the guy,
he did find way
to leave Facebook.
President Biden
announced yesterday
he will change the country's
coronavirus vaccination
strategy.
He's going with
reverse psychology.
"Fine, don't get one. No one
wants to hang out with you
in an indoor setting anyway.
In a new interview,
Republican Senator Josh Hawley
said he does not regret
pumping his fist
to cheer on the pro-Trump mo
that stormed the Capitol
on January 6th.
He honestly never thought
anyone would find him inspiring.
Senate Minority Leader
Mitch McConnell said recentl
that Republicans are willing t
negotiate with President Biden
over his $2.3 trillion
infrastructure proposal.
McConnell said there might b
some wiggle room
around the placement
of the decimal point.
House Minority Leader
Kevin McCarthy said recently
that the woke movement in this
country "has got to stop"
because it has led to
an absolute epidemic
of old white guys saying "woke."
Second Gentleman Doug Emhoff
traveled to Pennsylvania today
to meet with
small business owners,
as opposed to President Biden,
who spent the weekend
meeting with
small peanut farmers.
I'm sorry.
It's a weird picture.
I fear to look,
yet I cannot turn away.
President Biden said this week
that during his trip to Europe
in June,
he hopes and expects
to meet with Russian President
Vladmir Putin.
"That can be arranged," said
a paperweight on his desk.
According to a match.com survey,
71% of single people
have not had sex
since the coronavirus pandemic
started
and 91% of married people.
What do you think, Shoemaker
Am I in the 9% or the 91%?
-Oh, hi, now.
[ Laughter ]
-Shoemaker!
Star quarterback Tom Brady
said recently
that he would trade two of
his seven Super Bowl rings
to have won a championship
at the end of his 2007
undefeated season.
"Sorry, but we already
made a deal," said Satan.
Producers have announced
a new spin-off
of the "Law & Order" serie
entitled "Law & Order
for the Defense."
Turns out Dick Wolf isn't
even close to "dun-dun."
Every time you think
we've used the "dun-dun"
as a punch line for the last
it comes back around.
According to new research,
eating more nuts
can lead to weight loss
and better appetite control.
[ Clattering ]
Sorry, that was just every one
of my male writers
trying to get to cue cards
first.
A 1,692-foot-long
pedestrian suspension bridge
recently opened in Portuga
and takes at least four minute
to cross,
not to mention
three pairs of underwear.
And finally,
according to a new study,
men with larger noses
may also have larger penises
In case you're wondering why
this guy looks so smug
all the time...
Karen -- While all the guy
were running to cue cards,
Karen saw the possibilitie
in the Mr. Potato Head.
That was the monologue,
everybody.